hi guys
welcome on board thanks for joining in
I believe I'm Audible
all right guys uh
so today's session uh is on the Amazon
route 53.
which is basically a DNS mapping service
and a quite a useful service for
routing the website traffics domains
traffic to the to the web servers
and this way it helps you to put your
websites or the applications on the
production with the help of the route
53.
so let's look into what we have in the
Route 53 section today guys thanks for
joining in and
welcome on board let's continue
so what's in it for you today
we are going to understand about what
exactly the AWS is in brief we are going
to understand about the Amazon web
services
and then we are going to move to
the Amazon Route 53 service
what exactly the Amazon Route 53
services
what are the benefits of Route 53
types of different routing policies that
the Route 53 offers
Amazon Route 53 key features
how we can access Amazon Route 53 and
then I would be showing you one demo
where I would be using
a domain to Route the traffic
to one of the web servers hosted on the
AWS instance
so it's going to be a excited session
today
a lot of practical understanding you are
going to get about Route 53
now let's look into what exactly the AWS
is all about
so what is AWS
just a minute
and I believe you can view my screen
right
okay so coming back to the AWS so what
is AWS AWS stands for Amazon web
services it's a cloud provider that
offers a variety of services
such as compute power database storage
used for Content delivery and other
resources to help business scale and
grow
so Amazon web services is one of the
largest public Cloud providers
and when we say the public Cloud
providers that means anyone can work on
the Amazon web services they can create
their credentials and start using
so many services that the AWS offers
related to compute power
database Services storage services and
content delivery services along with
that
you can access Amazon web services for
various different business
functionalities like for machine
learning for iot and many more
so Amazon web service is easy to use for
a beginner
the platform is very much Interactive
it is designed to keep the data safe
irrespective of the size of the data
so people think
that the cloud
platforms primarily the public Cloud
platforms are not secured but Amazon web
services has taken a lot of security
measures
to keep the data safe and secure
irrespective of whatever the size of the
data you keep on the AWS infrastructure
it has a policy of pay as you go pricing
there are no long-term commitments and
hence it is cost effective one of the
major advantage of using the AWS and the
cloud platform is that whatever
resources you access or
whatever the resources that you are
working on you pay only for the duration
you are going to access them
that is what we call as a pay as you go
pricing
for example let's say if you launch a
virtual machine or a virtual server on
the AWS cloud and you use it for one
hour or two hour duration you you will
be billed only for that much duration
whether you use it for two hours three
hours or as many as much as you want
accordingly
the billing is going to happen
now let's try to understand about Amazon
route 53.
let's consider a scenario of an employee
Russell is trying to open a web a web
application
what challenge she is going to face the
challenge she faces is
the server usage is 100 percent
the memory usage is close to 100 the web
is not opening quickly it's just
circling around and then it is throwing
an error the web is not found it's a
disappointment for Russian
Rashel asked is there any efficient way
to scale resources according to user
requirements
is there a way that since the server
usage is 100 memory usage is 100 so
can there be a possibility to increase
the resources so that we can down the
server usage the memory usage it can be
reduced
the admin says yes on the AWS we can
scale resources efficiently
with the help of Amazon Route 53 service
so here if you look into this particular
symbol the symbol representation is of
an Amazon Route 53 that's how it looks
like
Amazon Route 53 is a DNS service domain
name service and that gives developers
an efficient way to connect users to
internet applications without any
downtime
so Route 53
is basically a DNS Management Service
and that's the reason that it is named
as a Route 53 because the DNS Port is
the 53 number the port number 53 is
where the DNS
works on
now what is exactly the dns's DNS is
basically a domain mapping to an IP
address and vice versa
right
so that's all what the Route 53 does in
terms of the DNS mapping services so
that the domains if the domains that are
purchased from any external resource or
from any external vendor the traffic
from the domain can be routed
to the web servers located on the AWS
Russell says that sounds interesting I
want to learn more about it how it can
be done
sure let me explain some important
concepts of Amazon Route 53 and
definitely we are going to work in a
practical way on the AWS as well
now let's look into what exactly the
Amazon Route 53 is all about what up
how does we work on the Route 53 and
what are the policies that the Route 53
offers
Amazon Route 53 is a highly available
and scalable DNS or domain name system
web service
this is how the Route 53 is represented
so whenever you see a diagram and
architecture and you find this
particular symbol that represents the
Route 53 only
Amazon Route 53 performs three main
functions in any combinations
what are those
the first one
if a website needs a name
Route 53
registers the name for the website
now what does that mean it means for
example
you're planning to host a website on the
AWS Cloud you're planning to launch your
website on the AWS Cloud but you are
finding a name a domain name through
which the users can open up your web
application or a website
for example the domain name could be
something like google.com
aws.com amazon.in
it can be anything msn.com yahoo.com
likewise these are all domain names
so likewise for your website you can
also
select a domain name
so Route 53 says
if a website needs a name you can
register the name of the website that
means it gives the registration services
as well you can find a domain directly
from the route 53. if you are thinking
to have a domain for your website you
can search if that is available on the
Route 53 or not
and then you can purchase on an annual
basis
the second functionality of our Route 53
is Route 53 helps to connect the browser
with the website or web application when
the user enters the domain name now
obviously that is the main thing for
which we use the route 53. for example
let's say I reserve
a domain
or a name for my website I take up an
example I reserve a name for my website
as www.example.com
now when somebody or let's say you open
up example.com you should be able to
open up my web page
so that means the example.com traffic
should be routed
to the server where the website code or
the website application is running
how we can achieve that functionality
that is something we can achieve it with
the help of the route 53.
so that's what the step two or the point
two suggests us that the Route 53 helps
to connect the browser with the website
or web application when the user enters
the domain name
Route 53 checks the health of the
resources by sending automated requests
over the internet to a resource so that
is also one of the important features of
the Route 53 it does the internal health
check of your website your application
running on multiple servers as well and
there are different type of routing
policies that you can specify so that
you can
cater the traffic coming from various
different locations across the globe
efficiently
now what are the benefits of Amazon
Route 53 let's look into it
the benefits of using Amazon route 53r
it is highly reliable absolutely
it ensures a consistent ability to Route
the applications
scalable
automatically handles large queries
without the user's interaction so you
can have different routing policies on
the basis you can
get the Route 53 handle
the sudden spike in the traffic towards
your website or your application
easy to use
it is easy to sign up configure DNS
settings and provide fast response to
queries
just two three steps that you need to
follow when you work on the Route 53 and
then you're going to find that your
website is live in in a in a time of
minutes only
cost effective pay only for the service
you use so depends on different type of
zones that you're going to create in the
Route 53 accordingly the billing is
going to happen so Route 53 is not that
expensive service definitely there will
be charges associated with the Route 53
service since it's a managed service by
the AWS but it is not that expensive
secure
the user secures the access rights by
integrating Route 53 with the AWS
identity access management so you can
integrate Route 53 with the IIM service
and accordingly you can delegate the
accesses of the route 50 with 53 to the
specific users
now Route 53 offers different type of
routing policies to us
what exactly the routing policies the
routing policy means that when
somebody tries to open up your website
tries to type a domain on the browser
let's say
www.example.com
now how that domain requests the traffic
request would go
to the backend server where the actual
website or the application is running
it is dependent on what type of a
routing policy that has been selected in
the Route 53
so there are various types of routing
policies that we can use based on the
type of an architecture
the type of a website or an architecture
that we are going to deploy on the AWS
if it's a small website where we are
expecting a traffic coming from a local
location a local region we can go for a
simple routing policy
and it depends again upon how much
traffic is expected from which location
the traffic is expected and how do you
want the availability and the
scalability to be planned so accordingly
we have to select the routing policies
so we have a simple routing policy which
is
one of the most easiest way of routing
the traffic to the backend websites or
the applications
now what does a simple routing policy do
the simple routing allows to configure
DNS with no special Route 53 routing
that means with the help of a simple
routing policy we can route the entire
domain traffic to a single server which
means that in the back end the website
or the web application would be running
only on a single server and the 100
traffic would go to that server only
there will be no bifurcation
it routes traffic to a single resource
example web server to a website
with simple routing multiple records
with same name cannot be created no it's
not possible the reason is because the
entire traffic is routed to a single
server so multiple records cannot be
created
but you can have multiple values that
can be specified in the same record set
so we are going to see that how we can
create multiple record set for the same
server in the simple routing policy
then we have another type of a routing
policy that is called as the failover
routing policy
now what happens on a failover routing
policy
the failover routing routes traffic to a
resource when the resource is healthy or
to a different resource when the
previous resources unhealthy
failover routing policy is just like an
active standby kind of a setup
so for example
let's say we are having two servers in
the back end where the same website or
an application is running
with the help of a failover routing
policy
the entire traffic coming from the
internet
from the domain would be routed directly
to one of the server
but the second server in the back end
will be kept as a standby as a backup
the second server is going to get the
traffic only when the first server is
not responding and this is why we use a
failover routing policy which is
primarily used for redundancy and for
the standby kind of a routing
so what I do guys before moving ahead
with other routing policies let's try to
understand how do we work on the Route
53 in the practical way and once we
achieve
the routing of a traffic to our backend
applications back-end servers then we
are going to further understand about
the other routing policies that the
Route 53 offers us let's look into it
so I have already logged in into the AWS
console
and
just a minute
just in case
okay
honeymoon
hello
hello
follow
hello
anmol
hello anmol
it will not display on the on the video
select
Google Chrome Google Chrome okay
all right guys so I believe you can see
my screen
let me check that just a minute
yeah
so here you can see I have moved to the
AWS console and I believe you guys know
how to login into the AWS console let me
show you quickly
so how to work on the AWS console is
first of all we have to go to Google so
the search engine type AWS console
the Management console
and here you need to select the AWS
Management console
click on sign in to the console
provide the user credentials
provide your password
and here you go we have logged in into
the AWS console
now we have to work on the route 53.
now to work on the Route 53 what are the
things that we require the first of all
we need to have an instance created the
ec2 instance created
and on that ec2 instance we need to have
a website or a web application running
and then we have need to have a domain
a domain can be purchased from the Route
53
or it can be purchased from any other
third party vendor like GoDaddy or web
hostinger
and the third thing is we need to have a
Route 53 Zone so these are the three
things that we require
to work on the Route 53 and Route the
traffic of a domain to the back end
servers
so that the domain becomes live
[Music]
so if you look into my screen
I have one domain that I have purchased
from GoDaddy GoDaddy is a third party
domain service and you can register the
domains from here you can purchase a
domain of your choice from here and here
you can see I have purchased one dummy
domain cloudlabs online.com
so we are going to use this particular
domain and we are going to Route the
traffic of this domain
to the instance that would be running on
our AWS console
so how we can do that let's look into it
[Music]
so first of all I'll move to the ec2
and though I have already created two
instances
where
the website or an application is running
and I believe you guys can also
host you you know how to host an
application on the instance otherwise I
can quickly show you how you can launch
a basic HTML web page on the ec2
instance and we can leverage that
Associated it with the route 53. so I'm
going to launch one instance the t2 dot
micro primarily let's say I name it as
something web server 3.
and uh
from the key pair perspective I'll
proceed without a key pair
and here I would allow the HTTP traffic
because the request would be coming
directly on the HTTP ports and launch an
instance
so here you can see I have launched one
instance
the web server 3 and I'm going to
leverage that with
my domain Cloud Labs on rent.com
[Music]
I'm just waiting for the instance to be
in a running state so that I can connect
I can quickly host a simple HTML
application on the server
and then we can link it up to The Domain
Cloud Labs on rent.com with the help of
the Route 53 service
now I'm going to connect to the instance
and obviously I'm going to connect using
a web connect only so click on connect
waiting for the console access here we
go
so I've been given easy to dash user
access and I will be moving to a root
user for that I'll be using a command
sudo SU
Edo super user and here I'm going to
install the Apache yum install http
guys we are not going in depth of how we
can host a application how we can work
on the Linux we are going to keep it
very simple because we need to
understand the functionalities of the
Route 53 service so I'm going to install
an Apache here
and
then I'm going to move
to the HTML directory
from ec2 Dash user directory I'll just
move to the HTML directory the command
is CD
slash triple W HTML
and here I'm going to create a simple
index.html or a PHP file whatever you
want
so I'm going to use Nano type command
index DOT type of file name index.html
and it opens up the file editor I'm not
going to write any HTML Tags I'm going
to get it from the internet itself
so I'm just going to find some HTML
codes that we can use
for our website
I'm just going to get a form copy the
entire code
and just going to paste it in our
file HTML
now we need to exit from here
so we need to press Ctrl and X together
to exit
press y to save the file and press the
enter key and here we go we are back to
the Shell
[Music]
now when you do list or List file
you get the index.html file is created
in the HTML directory
and if you want to read the code inside
this file you can always type cat
index.html or cat index.html5 more so
these are all Linux related things we
are just going to skip that
and the final thing from the server
perspective I'm just going to restart
the Apache so the command is service
HTTP restart
that's it
so now I'm going to close the shell
going back to the instance
the web server 3 and I'm going to see
whether we are able to get the web page
output directly from the server or not
so as all we know that when we create an
instance we get the public IP as well as
the private IP so I'm just going to
access the web page from the public IP
address so I'm going to copy the public
IP of the instance put that on the
browser and I'm going to send the HTTP
request to the server
here we go
so I'm able to get a my survey form and
this is coming from the index.html page
that I hosted on one of the ec2 instance
now guys I cannot
publish my website by putting up
the IP address
18.188.12.60 to my users to the clients
I need to link it
with the domain
so what I'm going to do I'm going to use
a Route 53 service so that I can map
This Cloud Labs on rent.com and point it
to this server IP
with that if anyone opens cloudlabs on
rent.com on the browser they are going
to get the same output and that's how we
publish
are websites
let's see how we can achieve this
now we need to understand the
functionality of our Route 53 so we'll
move to the Route 53 service
I'll just search for it
click on the Route 53
and if you have observed here the Route
53 is a global Service
we don't have to select a region and the
best thing is for the Global Services
are
when we work on the Global Services we
can leverage any region we can route the
traffic to any of the region wherever
our web servers are located
so it's a centrally managed service the
entire management of the service is done
in the back end by AWS
and what we are going to do now is
we are going to understand the
components of the Route 53 how we are
going to work on it as I mentioned in
the slides
you can even register a domain on the
route 53. So This Cloud Labs on red
domain I have purchased from GoDaddy if
you want you can get it directly
from the AWS as well
how
when you go to the Route 53 dashboard
just go scroll down go to the domains
and click on registered domains
and then it asks you to search for a
domain just click on register domain
again
and type a domain of your choice and see
whether it is available or not
let's say I want to get a domain
something related to
example cloud.com
and check
and it says examplecloud.com is not
available let me try to search something
else route53.com
it says yay example route 53.com is
available and you can get it for twelve
dollars a year annual subscription
you can add to card and you can pay as
well
so this way you can use this domain for
one year and after that again you have
to renew the subscription
so we are not going to register any
domain we already have a domain we are
going to see how we can map it to our
ec2 instance so again I'm going back to
the Route 53 dashboard
and what we need to do is first of all
we have to create a hosted zone so when
we work on the Route 53 specifically in
this kind of Demos in these kind of
examples there are two things that we
need to work on in the Route 53 one is
we need to create a hosted Zone
and the second thing is we need to
create a record set which is created
inside the hosted Zone these are the two
things that we need to remember
now what exactly the hosted zone is
a hosted Zone tells Route 53 how to
respond to the DNS queries for a domain
so when we create a hosted Zone it gives
us
some four DNS servers or the name
servers
and those name servers are going to
resolve the request coming from
the cloud Labs on rent.com domain which
will be done by the route 53.
so this is the first thing to progress
and hence I'm going to click on create a
hosted Zone
provide a domain let's say I provide the
domain name as Cloud Labs on rent
dot com
and it is going to be a public hosted
Zone because our domain is on the public
network it's on third party
and click on create a hosted Zone
so once you create a hosted Zone
you would get you would get four name
servers these are the DNS servers that
means these are going to resolve
the domain name coming from the traffic
coming from GoDaddy
and SOA is starts of authority so right
now we don't have to work on the start
of authority it gives you the DNS
information only
we need to focus more on the name
servers the fourname servers
so what we need to do is
we need to tell
these four name servers
to a platform
from where we have purchased the domain
we need to update these fourname servers
on a platform where we have purchased a
domain
so I have purchased a domain on GoDaddy
so I have to tell GoDaddy that this
domain should be resolved by
these four name servers that are
provided by route 53.
now what benefit we get the benefit we
get is
when anyone tries to access Cloud Labs
on rent.com on the browser the request
for resolution the name resolution
request goes to these four name servers
that are running on the AWS
so that way we are able to Route the
traffic towards the AWS this becomes the
first stage
completion
so how we can update these four name
servers onto the platform from where we
have purchased the domain what we need
to do is let's say we go to GoDaddy
find our domain
go to the DNS for the name servers click
on change
enter my own name servers click on it
and here we are going to delete the
existing name servers and we are going
to update
the new name servers that we got from
the Route 53 hosted Zone
what we need to do is we have to update
all the four name servers on GoDaddy so
you just have to copy the name server
and exclude the last dot you don't have
to copy the entire link just have to
exclude the last Dot copy it
paste it
step by step you have to complete this
activity
copy
till the and exclude the last Dot
again the third one copy it
include the last Dot
and the final one
so these four name servers are provided
for the extraordinary energy generally
uh if you try to host a
domain on any of the third party tools
they provide you two name servers but
the good thing about AWS is it gives you
provide your full name servers that
gives you a better redundancy better
resolution of name faster way
and click on Save
yes I consent to update name servers for
the selected domains click on continue
and all these name servers are updated
on the third party too that is GoDaddy
from where we have purchased the domain
now we are going back to the AWS
and the final thing is we need to create
a record set
so we have to click on create a record
now why the record sets are created
because
by hosted Zone we are able to get the
traffic on the AWS now from the AWS we
have to Route the traffic to the
instance where our website is running
and for that we have to create a record
set
so we'll go to the record set
provide the record name so we can have
multiple resource names multiple sources
we can create so here I can put
something like triple w dot
cloudlabsonrent.com
and you can select a record type a
generally if you have to route a traffic
directly to one single server using an
IP address then we prefer to use a route
traffic to an ipv4 address and some AWS
resources in case if you are going to
router traffic to a load balancer for
example so we don't get
the IP address for the load balancers we
only get the DNS neighbor so in that
case we have to use the C names
right the common name
so right now I'm going to show you how
we can router traffic
to a single server
using the public IP address of that
instance
and then I am going to show you how we
can work on the cname as well because we
have the load balancer also created
and here in the value we have to specify
the IP address of an instance where our
website the actual website is running
so we'll go to the instance
find the IP address of
the server the web server 3.
copy and paste that in the values
click on create a records
and here
you can see we have created a record set
as well
so if anyone tribe tries to access
triple w dot cloudlabsonrent.com that
request would go to this IP address and
the web page to the user would receive
would be retrieved from the
18.188.12.60 IP address which belongs to
our web server where the website is
running
all right I can add more record sets
also I can
make the changes here itself
and it is up to the requirement only
all right
now we are going to test whether we can
get an output from
www.cloudlabsonrent.com and we should
get an output of our
web page this web page should be able to
open from the domain let's look into it
so I'm going to open up a browser type
triple W Cloud Labs on rent.com
and here we go
we got the output now where exactly this
webpage is coming from this webpage is
coming from this particular web server 3
because here we have hosted that
this way we can publish
our websites now our website can be like
further on it I can add the SSL
certificates make it more secure I can
create a record set for with HTTP URL
with the https URL many more resources
we can add up along with that in the
Route 53 we can add the email records as
well uh the SPF records we can add it up
so that to our website we can have an
backend email client configure a lot of
things we can
I hope guys you got an idea how to work
on the Route 53 now in case
if you have multiple servers
in the back end
in different regions or let's say in the
same region but there are multiple
servers in that same region and you want
the Route 53 to Route the traffic of the
domain to the multiple servers with the
help of a load balancer so how you can
achieve that let's look into it
I have already created a load balancer
the classic load balancer
and to the clb we have a DNS name
the public BNS name
and with this load balancer I have
attached two instances in the back end
both are right now in the stop state
likewise I can add the third instance
also the web server 3. but we are going
to work with these two instances only as
of now
so what I'm going to do I'm going to
start these two instances from the ec2
dashboard
and then I am going to link the load
balancer with
the domain Cloud Labs on red.com with
the help of our outfit
so once the instances are started
we'll move to the Route 53
here we are going to edit the record
and instead of a record type I am going
to use a cname
because for the load balancer we don't
have the public IPS we don't have any IP
we have only the DNS name
and for the DNS name you have to use a
cname so likewise you can use a load
balancer you can use an S3 static
website endpoint also you can use Lambda
functions also you can even use elastic
Beanstalk DNS names
pointed to your backend applications
cloud formation DNS names you can use
even cloudfront domain names also you
can use with the help of a common name
routing
so we'll click on the common name
routing and here I'm just going to paste
the public DNS name of the load balancer
click on create a record and then you
would see
the traffic from the triple W Cloud Labs
on rent.com would be routed to this load
balancer and in the load balancer we are
having two instances so equally the web
page would be retrieved
from one of the instances so equal
distribution of the load is going to
happen
equal distribution of the load is going
to be done by the load balancer in the
back end
now guys coming to the routing policies
so right now whatever the demo that I
have shown
is by using a simple routing policy that
means we are routing the request of a
domain and pointing it to one single
Source in the back end
either it will be a backend server
or it is a back-end load balancer but
it's a single entity
so the hundred percent traffic from the
Internet is routed to that entity
but with the help of routing policies
you can
distribute the traffic among different
regions also based on the architecture
need based on the functionality and
that's what we were understanding
when we were covering up the slide so we
covered up the simple routing policy
we covered up the failover routing
policy that is primarily used for active
standby and let's try to understand some
more routing policies that we can use
with the route 53.
so I'm moving to the slides
just a minute
open the slide let me begin the
slideshow
and here we go
so before the demo we understood the
concept of the failover routing policy
which is primarily an active standby
kind of a routing policy and by now you
should be having an idea what exactly
this Route 53 services and how do we
work on it and how we can use different
type of routing policies
so we saw the simple routing policy how
do we work on failover routing policy
when we use it is primarily used for
routing the traffic to an active server
and then when that active server fails
the traffic is
transmitted or routed to the back end
server or the standby server
the records can also route to Route
traffic to anything from an Amazon S3
bucket as a website to a complex tree of
record so you can use it with the S3
endpoints as well bucket hosting
endpoints you can use it with Cloud
functions uh sorry you can use it with
cloud formations
even with the Lambda functions and many
other resources
now let's look into the geolocation
routing
the geolocation routing routes the
resources that based on the geographical
location of the users so let's say if
you are having our web servers running
in different
geographical locations or different
regions let's say I have one web server
in one of the US region then another web
server in APAC the third web server in
emir
and based on the user's location let's
say if a user tries to access the domain
from the US the request would go
to the web server in the US location
if anyone from the Asia Pacific tries to
access that domain the request would go
to a backend server in the Asia Pacific
location only that is what the
geolocation routing are used for and
that reduces the latency so that quickly
the users can able to open up the web
page and there is a uniform latency that
is
maintained
it localizes the content and presents
part of the entire website in the
language of the user
the geographical locations are specified
by the continent by country or by state
let's say in the United States
then we have a geoproximity routing
there is a slight difference between a
geolocation and the geoproximity routing
let's look into it ideally it is almost
similar but there is a slight difference
between the geoproximity and the
geolocation routing
the geoproximity routing routes traffic
to the resources based on the
geographical location of the users and
their resources that is what the
geolocation also does
but there is an option to Route more
traffic or less to a given resource by
specifying a value known as bias so we
can
increase the area of a region
with the help of a geoproximity object
or we can decrease the area of the
region
with the help of a geoproximity routing
and that's what it says there is an
option to Route more traffic or less
depends on a rows resource depends on
how big the server is running which
location the server is running from
where the traffic is coming and that is
something which you can control which is
not possible in the case of a
geolocation routing
a bias expands or shrinks the size of
the geographical region from which the
traffic is routed to a resource
so you can have more States added
in that particular location you can
reduce the number of states also and
accordingly from that particular
geographical location the traffic will
be routed to the respective resources on
the AWS
then comes the latency based routing so
as the name suggests it is primarily
required to perform or to provide a
uniform latency
so it is not dependent on the region or
a location from where the traffic is
originating or where exactly the servers
are located on the AWS it is absolutely
based on
which region
resource are going to give the lowest
latency to the user and from there the
request would be completed
so in a latency based routing if a
website has to be installed or hosted
across multiple AWS regions then latency
routing policy is used
it improves the performance for the
users by serving the request from the
AWS region that provides the lowest
latency now let me take an example for
let us say I am based out in India
and there are
servers running in Mumbai and one server
running in Singapore but at present if I
try to access a web page
the Mumbai location or the region is
offering more latency as compared to
Singapore region so with the help of a
latency based routing the Route 53 is
going to route my request to access that
web page to a Singapore location server
rather than to a Mumbai location server
but if you calculate a geographical
distance geographical location Mumbai is
nearby but that is offering more latency
so latency based routings are not
related to a location they are based on
absolutely based on the current
situation
which particular region or the location
is giving the lowest latency from that
user's Network
to use latency based routing
we should create less latency records
for the resources in multiple AWS
regions
then we have a multi-value answer
routing and this is one of the best way
of doing a routing policy in case if you
are not able to find out which routing
policy you should be using whether you
should be using a failover routing
policy or a latency based routing policy
or geolocation based routing policy the
best thing is use a multi-value answer
routing now in the case of a multi-value
answer routing what happens is it does
the internal health check of the
resources the applications running on
the servers or your websites running on
the servers
and whosoever
returns the request faster they are the
actual or the production traffic will be
routed
so multi-value routing configures Route
53 to return multiple values in response
to the DNS queries
it also checks the health of resources
and return the multiple values only for
the healthy resources
so whichever server
gives is most healthier as compared to
the other servers that server is going
to get
the request for a web page from the
internet
it has an ability to return multiple
Health checkable IP addresses to improve
availability
and load balancing
then we have a weighted routing policy
this is something related to a load
balancing only
just like a load balancer when we use a
load balancer on the cloud
what does the load balancer do it routes
a request to the backend server equally
based on the algorithm
but with the help of the weighted
routing policy we can segregate away we
can specify a percentage and we can do a
cross region waited out in policy also
on the AWS when we use the load balancer
the cross region load balancing is a bit
difficult to achieve but with the help
of the Route 53 weighted routing policy
we can have a cross region balancing as
well and we can specify the weight or
the percentage as well
we can specify that more of the traffic
should be going to a server in the U.S
location
some part of the percentage of the
traffic should be going to the server
and the Emir location likewise in the
Asia Pacific location so likewise based
on from where exactly the request
for the web page is going to come from
Mostly accordingly the percentage of the
weight is specified
so in the case of a weighted routing
policy weighted routing routes multiple
resources with a single domain name or
subdomain name and control the traffic
that is routed to each resource so guys
it is a bit tricky to use a weighted
routing policy and I would appreciate
that if you go to the AWS documentation
try to understand how the formula is
used for using the weighted routing
policy and accordingly you can plan it
uh plan the traffic on the proportions
where you want to send the request to
it is useful load balancing and testing
new version of the software
and that's what
the routing policies we have now coming
back to the Route 53 key features what
all things we observed or what are the
functionalities we get from the Route 53
traffic flow it routes end users to the
endpoint that should provide the best
user experience we have seen that
domain registration select domain names
and register them with the AWS console
we can
choose a domain we can pick a domain and
we can purchase it from the cloud 53 as
well
health checks it monitors health and
performance of the application so
internal health check of an application
keeps on Happening by the Route 53 so
that
only
the production traffic can be routed to
the servers which are the most healthier
one if let's say if our application our
web page a website got an error so
ideally we should not
we would not want that the production
traffic should be reaching to that
particular server in the back end and
this is something which is eliminated
with the help of the Route 53 internal
hey check parameter
weighted round robbing load balancing it
spreads traffic between several Services
via a road Robin algorithm and we can do
a cross region round ribbon
uh load balancing as well with the help
of a route 53.
accessing Amazon Route 53
Amazon Route 53 can be accessed in the
following way you can access it using
the AWS Management console we have seen
that in the demo
we can access it from the software
development kits or the sdks but we need
to install the SDK on our local system
of the host systems to access it
we can even access the Route 53 from the
Route 53 API that the AWS offers which
is
using an API we can put or we can
instruct how the Route 53 should work
and also we can access the Route 53
using the command line interface so CLI
we can access it using the cloud shell
or we can install the CLI on our host
machines as well
along with that we can access the Route
53 using the AWS tools for windows power
shell as well in case if you are going
to use a Windows host machine
what all companies are using Route 53
mostly
Airbnb we know about Airbnb that is
apartment rental service Reddit
instacart
and then you have I think it's pin
interest stripe medium these are some of
the uh big companies that are presently
using around 53 for their number
so when you type airbnb.com for example
reddit.com or any any of these domains
the route request is sent to the servers
on the AWS with the help of the Route 53
only
we have seen the demo how we can route
the traffic
from the domain
purchased on GoDaddy to the Route 53
with the help of the Route 53 to one of
the instance and the load balancer and
we have seen that how does it works guys
I hope you liked uh today's session if
you have any questions please let me
know so I open up the session for the
question and answers let me know for any
queries you have guys
if anyone is having any questions please
let me know
no questions
please feel free to ask any questions
guys
I think now after watching this video
you should be able to even host a simple
website try this demo on your AWS
accounts make sure that you use a free
tier instance and try to get a domain
and Route the traffic with the help of
the route 53.
so we have couple of minutes before we
end this
session
any questions
please feel free to ask
so likewise we are going to get some
more exciting demos when we when you
guys are going to join the full course
for simply learn and let's catch on
there itself
all right guys so if there are no
further questions
I'm just going to wrap up today's
session
and I wish you all the best for your
upcoming assignments take care bye now
guys wish you all a Merry Christmas and
a